i'm going to see some trash day specials
next year will you guys
go in those sort of places
why those places
like we got to do exciting things yeah
people want to see torture
there's there's more interesting ways
guantanamo
what a
they put a tea towel over my face
i put a tea towel in my face then
covered me in tea
and it was like this is waterboarding
isn't it numbers what do they mean chris
they like this towel on my face there's
like liquid pouring down
and then she was like
i'm like
the room number what's the room number
yeah
my god just be careful you get a massage
in japan
experience ever it was um i went as one
go-to and it was included in the hotel i
thought oh why not i've never gone for a
massage before
why not what could go wrong
so you know i'm face down on this
massage table you know it's already
quite awkward she's really like sheepish
about everything and then you know and
struggling to like explain to me to take
off my shirt and whatnot yeah okay yeah
i lie down and i'm like chilling and
then i feel like
i hear like she's just like she's
preparing like oils and stuff and then
just smashing like glass breaking
and then i'm like awkwardly like what's
going on and then she's trying to like
stealthily pick up this glasses if she
hadn't broke it like like a whole lot i
had to realize and i could just hear her
like every now and then i could just
hear a little like
and i'm just like it's okay just get the
[ __ ] broom it's already too late
like what are you gonna say you've got a
glass massage yeah it's like a shatters
a bottle over your head inside the
realms of possibility of what i
experienced she was so awkward it was
like 40 minutes of this poor woman
trying to pick up this uh this class and
i was just like just go at it i don't
give a [ __ ] it's already the ambiance
sorry ruined do you want a massage in
japan girl i am not a fan of massages
but that's because like i'm used to thai
massages where oh right it's like just
like beat the [ __ ] out of you i'm not a
fan that's my first time and i don't
think i want another one yeah okay
i don't mind massages but i'm usually
not that stiff
so
i don't really
i don't really need a massage
you know
we're trying to talk it out
maybe
when you get your haircut here sometimes
they just start massaging you it's
really [ __ ] weird yeah yeah like it's
okay i didn't i didn't pay for that yeah
i i i'm like because i'm like 10 in my
head i laugh they're like they're like
i'm like
[Music]
and the guy's like don't you i'm like
yeah
because i'm like 10 in my head
i don't know it's weird i just i laugh
at that when they massage weekends
japanese service like
beyond extra it's like you do not need a
massage or you're getting your hair cut
yeah it's just the weirdest ones is when
they're like shampooing you and then
they start massaging your head yeah
yeah i like that i got natsuki did that
to me once i just felt really
uncomfortable
as a beauty seller right i was like
that's this is a bit weird
because you don't see him as the kind of
guy yeah
stroking your head
i think the weirdest place i got a
massage was i was staying in this like
high-class hotel in thailand um and of
course they want to make it seem like
you know they they have service people
everywhere so of course you know in in
some hotels they have people in the
toilet to uh hand out towels
right
to hand out towels and you know just you
know freshen up if you if you need to
freshen up so i'm going to and the guy
asked me if i want to tell and i said no
no it's okay so i go up and go to the
urinal
and i hear some footsteps what's going
on is there someone else about um and
then i feel two hands on my shoulder
as i'm missing
and i'm just like and it's just like the
most awkward piss i've had in my life oh
my god i'm like i'm like it's at this
point it's just like it's just it's like
i'm like struggling to get it out now
because i'm going i have someone
my shoulders as i'm like trying to piss
in this urinal right and he must have
saw how stiff you
say oh you're a bit stiff there buddy
all right so we finished and i go up to
uh i go up to the sink to wash my hands
and i look at him and he's expecting a
tip from oh i'm just like
which one
i think i think you already gave him a
tip
it's probably the most awkward tip i've
given in my life because i'm just like i
really don't want to give you this tip i
can just imagine you just like slowly
turning around it's just like the jojo
like behind the shoulder
i think i'd rather have waterboarding
with teeth
than have like urinal piss massage
that's awful that's that must be on the
top ten list of places you don't want to
be massive yeah yeah yeah pushing in a
urinal
that's got to be up there
[Music]
abandoned i already know like when
people talk to me when i'm standing in
front of you right let alone getting
massage
christ wow any other any other places
you've been massaged
i think that's that's it yeah
let's never speak of massages again
by the way congrats on getting verified
by the way i don't think you i don't
think you were verified last time uh oh
that's that's like beyond getting a
studio be on camera yeah
you got twitter verified
that was the real um gold star
you got verified before trash taste yes
yeah so you technically won the bit it
turned
there one time it was like done in like
one minute
i got a bit too big for my beats
did they ask she's like submit an imdb
or something how did they define that it
was like something like that and i was
just doing it right
[Laughter]
because i've had like new year chris
oh [ __ ] i don't know
there's lots of cool things um yeah
what's the oh too much volcano yeah oh
yeah we talked about that top 14 19 is
here probably that and then why'd you
say top 14 just say it was 14th
christmas top 14. top 14. you know what
did you say top 50. how much did it make
it made like it made a whopping how much
do you think it made
top 14 20 thousand dollars
um
how much do you think well i'll tell you
how much money yeah i ironed
yeah is that how you found the budget to
build your new studio that is it that's
the money went towards that he said he
would split it but we never saw the
money
i gave you a trip to hokkaido
he invited me to the studios like he's
too much volcano money right here thank
you
i mean yeah it's been a good year like
the studio is good and yeah the
kenworthy thing right they're supposed
to get the kimono documentary out
in december but
it's just really hard to edit it i i'm
really like embarrassed watching it back
because i i completely crumbled as an
interviewer i was going to try and speak
japanese to him yeah and then my mind
just went when i'm because it's just
weird you're sitting here there's ken
white
he's got a coffee i've got a coffee i'm
like
so then ken oh god and also i didn't
sleep the night the night before i met
him i didn't sleep at all because i'm
nervous yeah i was [ __ ] there oh yeah
i was like
i think anyone would be i was nervous as
hell i didn't sleep at all and so i was
like uh ken um that's rubbish
my performance i wasn't happy with it
you said you were starstruck
it was it a little bit but not he's
quite not just a normal guy he was in
last samurai
[Music]
and also like the best actor in japan
but like a normal guy
but
it was just weird it's just so trippy i
was just sitting there with ken martial
it was really weird
i just like how you just call him a
normal guy in life he's a horrible guy
he's he's another normal guy
oscar-nominated japanese actor that tom
guy is a pretty normal guy as well tom
blake i mean i don't blame you i think
anyone from [ __ ] things
he spoiled inception for me though told
me they told me about this he was like
yeah i've seen it you know there's a
spinner that keeps on going oh yeah for
interpretation the endings and he's like
he's like he's like oh it just keeps on
spinning oh like he's he's in the dream
world i was like i was like you've just
ruined inception for me oh no he's he's
in the real world mike michael kane
actually ruined it i think
because i believe
that
he's in the i was kenzie was in the fake
world
and he was like he was in the script but
it was what's real it was in the script
or something i i think they actually
i think i actually broke her down for
like to like i think leonardo dicaprio
wears a ring or something in the real
world or like that's how you distinguish
between dream world and the real world
it's i think he wears a ring or there's
a piece of item on him that makes it
distinguish between real world and dream
world and in the last scene
he is in the real world would it be
would it be a large stretch to say that
both michael caine and ken watson have
it may possibly be speculating it's
possible but i think the chemistry yeah
yeah yeah
yeah maybe
he said it's in the script that said
that i'm pretty excited i i don't think
it was in the script i think nolan told
them individually so maybe they just
told them different things yeah maybe
yeah it was like it's real
in the documentary i did at the end i
want to be like i had this scene i'm
like can i want to have like a spinner
and pretend like i don't know if in the
real world or not because i'm
interviewing kim what's navi or
something and apparently he's like yeah
sure he's really good at the spinner and
he said in inception every time they
needed like a spinner he would just come
out and be the one that did it because
he was like the best like spinning it
little facts about what time for that
he's great it's meaning
spinning man
you've been in the last samurai spinning
normal spinning man in the last house
what makes him normal right
he can spin [ __ ]
i was intimidated until he got his
spinner out i started spinning it's like
oh wow thank god just a normal guy
[Laughter]
it's quite a serious documentary yeah
yeah it doesn't come out i need to see
it for myself if it's if it's actually
crumbly chris or if it's just like well
like
i'm gonna like use cgi to like make me
look good and be like the best
we need a question
hello there ken how are you doing and i
have like some weird synthesized version
of it but like i don't know i'm still
editing it and uh to make me look good
and not [ __ ]
because you feel like we normally do an
editing yeah you filmed that like a
couple months ago you filmed it in like
october and november yeah i met him
twice yeah how long is it going to be
25 minutes maybe oh yeah and it might be
out by the time this episode is out
maybe
yeah um
maybe maybe it's going to get better
yeah but maybe
it was good i went for dinner with him
and you know lots of people and like
this man at this restaurant just came up
to him and ken the whole premise
documentary is he's like worked to help
sort of recover this town called
kesanuma they call it destroyed by the
tsunami and then he's got a cafe there
and he's done a lot of great stuff for
it but like we're just out for dinner
and like this man just comes up and he's
like oh ken sounds smart
thank you for the
that's why it's funny he's like thank
you for the trumpets
like it turned out ken had to really
generously like donate like a thousand
trumpets to the town two thousand that's
probably more kids than are in the town
there's nothing he might be why why
trump does he plays the trumpet he's
like to get everyone a trumpet so just
like this man just compensation i like
trump and he's like you've misremembered
this no he's like ken thank you get
yourself a trumpet thank you everyone
why because i like trump thank you for
the trumpet thank you for the trumpets
ken he's like what about the trumpets oh
yeah
what are you gonna do for the people of
wales
i
i just have this image of ken watanabe
going to this village which has been
like decimated by the tsunami and it
just goes you know what you need here's
a thousand trumpets you need a trumpet
to help the restoration efforts you know
but he's done an incredible job there
and i think that's really nice like he's
you know a lot of celebrities they get
involved just for the sake of it for pr
but he's actually befriended everyone
there and it's gone right now
samurai top spinner trumpet dealer what
isn't it when are you donating
they'll come to me i'll be like thank
you for feeding my children in front of
chris i'll pay someone to come up and do
it
when i'm in wales i'll organize it
someone to come just get the entire town
to like be in it
keep coming up to me thank you connor
thank you and christopher what's up i'll
die about it
what do you donate chris well i don't
know yeah
very much chicken probably
bucket of chicken that's why there's a
shortage right
the cholesterol of kent is gonna go
through the roof
all right